bilan les à l'obscur 200 millions 500
mille entrées en 2010 mais le cinéma
résiste en france et ce malgré la
concurrence de la télé des tablettes et
des smartphones retour dans les années
à l'époque chaque année plus de 300
millions d'entrées sont rendus mais une
menace arrive et prend de la place dans
nos salons dans les années 60 c'est le
téléviseur santé révisant cha cha tv la
télé nouveau chouchou des français à la
fin des années 70 il devient possible
d'enregistrer les programmes sur
cassette
si vous gardez cette cassette pour votre
usage personnel
aucun problème en revanche si vous la
vendez ou si vous la louer à un ami par
exemple vous êtes devenu un pirate
amateur depuis le développement de la
télé la fréquentation des salles de
cinéma s'est érodée en 1960 plus de 354
millions de tickets se sont vendus puis
les français en petit à petit déserté
les salles et en 1992
les entrées ont chuté à 116 millions le
pire score à ce jour
la faute au petit écran mais aussi aux
prix trop élevé selon l'insee même avec
le prix étudiant à 30
les années suivantes les chiffres
repartent à la hausse poussée par des
super productions spectaculaires sur
grand écran comme titanic
toujours 3 millions ça sur les entrées
je n'ai jamais vécu années 2000 un autre
écran menace la fréquentation en salles
celui d'un ordinateur avec internet en
haut débit
les français découvrent le streaming et
le téléchargement tous deux illégaux
les films se copie sur dvd où
s'échangent par clé usb
pour autant tous ne sont pas pessimiste
quant à la fréquentation des salles
sortir pour voir un film pour refaire le
monde après à partir d'un film et
discuter dans un petit bistrot dans un
café dans un restaurant ça fait partie
de l'art de vivre un art de vivre
la salle de cinéma reste fédératrice
sans doute grâce à une qualité de son et
d'image bien supérieure à celle des
films qui circulent sur internet
jusqu'en 2010 le grand écran attire les
spectateurs la barre des 200 millions
est à nouveau déplacement
[Musique]
pourtant depuis 2010 la fréquentation
des salles se stabilise au dessus des
200 millions d'entrées annuelles
l'expérience du grand écran a toujours
une place dans le coeur des français
[Musique]